c'est le statu quo vauquelin le port de
pêche est toujours en sable et les
marins pêcheurs n'en peuvent plus de
cette situation qui les pénalise
ils ont donc décidé d'inviter des
membres de l'asso pamart afin qu'ils
puissent constater sur place les
difficultés auxquelles ils sont
confrontés
j'étais absolument et est catastrophé
lors que on m'a expliqué que jusqu où
arrivaient les bateaux ou est-ce qu'ils
acceptent vous déposer leur passion et
l'état de la situation
naturellement nous sommes créés
interpellé par le traitement des boues
pour lui mais ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
que le problème se pose
et à chaque fois que le problème s'est
posé on a pu trouver des solutions
ailleurs on est très mal dans la
profession voeckler parce que on subit
les sargasses l'ensablement qui nous
empêche d'accoster de débarquer de faire
de l'essence qui nous bouzzine au moteur
est ce que je fais aujourd'hui gelée
déjà fait mille et une fois et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à renier on se retrouve à
tourner à droite à gauche
aller dans des unions ne pas aller au
travail on espère avoir une réponse
positive il ya toujours des marins
pêcheurs qui ne comprennent donc pas que
les travaux de désensablement du port
n'est pas encore commencé alors que
toutes les démarches ont été effectuées
par les professionnels et la ctm pour
obtenir les autorisations nécessaires
les documents demandés ont été fournis
mais on leur demande les mêmes pièces et
le dossier n'avance pas on a
l'impression qu'on se moque de nous
pourquoi parce qu'en fait via un
communiqué de la des halles disant qu'il
n'avait pas reçu de dossier alors que
j'ai un document de la des halles disons
qu'ils ont reçu le dossier fin novembre
les autorisations que l'éclat de ses
autorisations en fait d'eux des
propriétaires de terrains où seront
entreposés le sable qui sera en fait
sortis du bois or ses propres
propriétaires sont la commune du vauclin
qui vient entendu a déjà donné son
autorisation puisque la commune nous
soutient et a déjà mis à disposition les
terrains à cet effet et l'autre vont
prier terre en fait c'est l'état donc
les autorisations je ne sais pas qui
pourrait les données à parler tu as tu
déjà un an que les marins pêcheurs du
vauclin subissent cette situation il est
hors de question pour eux que l'année
2019 des buts sans que le problème ne
soit réglé ils se disent prêts à se
mobiliser avec la sopa marais a mené des
actions coup de poing
si des travaux de dragage du port ne
sont pas lancés rapidement